[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about what happens after
the tournament of power the tournament
is the current epic saga of Dragon Ball
super that is expected to run until
March of 2018
now obviously the tournament of power
has really raised the stakes in Dragon
Ball super the strongest fighters from 8
different universes facing off against
each other
with the existence of their entire
universes being on the line we've
already seen a bunch of universes erased
from existence including universe 6 in
one of the most emotional Dragon Ball
super episodes to date it doesn't get
much more important or much more
interesting than that so where does
Dragon Ball super go from here provided
that the series continues past the
universe survival arc and there is no
reason why it shouldn't because Dragon
Ball super is extremely popular
worldwide the big question is how can
they top the tournament of power how can
they keep the audience interested after
all of these universes battling each
other for their very survival this is
the question that we'll be talking about
in this video and I will be analyzing
some of the most interesting theories
about what will happen after the
tournament and I will also let you know
which theories I personally agree and
disagree with although I always welcome
your views and opinions in the comments
for this video especially I want to get
a good conversation going about what's
next for Dragon Ball super so definitely
give me your take down below if you
enjoy the Dragon Ball super content on
this channel be sure to leave a like to
let me know and if you are new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to support
the channel and get cool anime merch
like your girl calls me senpai and keep
calm an ultra instinct you can check out
our merch store link in the description
now the first thing that we need to talk
about in terms of what happens after the
tournament is how the tournament will
end because those two things will likely
be closely related a lot of things are
towards a rematch and final showdown
between Jaden in ultra in sting Goku and
I personally can't wait to see that
happen however we still don't know just
how powerful jeera and truly is he has
been so calm and confident throughout
the tournament that he could still be
holding back and if Jaden is holding
back and he didn't use his full
potential even during his fight against
ultra instinct oh man Goku then we have
to ask ourselves how will go you managed
to defeat him we'll go to attain yet
another level beyond ultra instinct omen
that will allow him to move beyond the
power of G Ren or will he be forced to
do something drastic like fuse with
Vegeta to create ultra instinct vegeto
after kale and cauliflower allowed to
use the Patara to fuse into kefla the
stage was set for other Patara fusions
during the tournament of power including
the potential fusion between Goku and
Vegeta
we know that Vegeta told Kappa that if
universe 6 lost in the tournament then
he would wish them back into existence
using the super Dragon Balls because
super shunran's power is described as
without limits as long as there is only
one wish we can assume that wishing
universe 6 back with the super Dragon
Balls is indeed possible in Dragon Ball
Z the Dragon Balls were used to bring
back everyone who was killed by free
zionist forces on Namek and also
everyone who was killed by cell and the
androids on earth so if super Shenron
being more powerful than any of the
other dragons can indeed revived entire
universes it may be possible for Goku or
Vegeta or someone else to wish back
literally everyone who was erased by
Zeno during the tournament of power
thereby bringing back all of the
universes and all of the life inside of
them
super Shenron and the super Dragon Balls
will obviously play a major role after
the tournament ends but the question is
who will get to make the wish if
universe 7 wins that we can safely say
that someone like Goku or Vegeta will
wish back the other unit
but what about Frieza he has been very
cunning during the tournament saving his
own stamina while still helping the
members of his own team because of
course he wants to win but what will he
do when the time comes to decide who
gets to make the wish in episode 95
Frieza was able to overcome cedras
energy of destruction showing that even
before the tournament he had become
extremely powerful and in episode 99
Frieza says about Zen oh one day I
promise I shall reign over you clearly
if Frieza somehow manages to be the last
man standing on the universe 7 team his
priority will not be to wish back the
other universes but to wish himself back
to life permanently and also let's face
that he will probably find some way to
make the wish turn him into the most
powerful being in existence freeze up
being the one to make the wish and
wishing to become more powerful than the
Omni King for example would change
everything and turn Frieza yet again
into the ultimate villain no I'm not
saying this is definitely gonna happen
in fact personally I doubt it but it's
definitely a possibility on the other
hand if universe 7 by some chance
doesn't win and jiren wins instead what
will he wish for as a pride trooper he
loves justice so will his love of
justice compel him to wish back all the
other universes if universe 7 somehow
loses in the end and then they are
actually erased I am betting that girion
will wish them back because of course
there can be no Dragon Ball super
without universe 7 but I am definitely
interested to see how the series will
handle who wins and then who gets to
make the wish another option is that
instead of relying on the super Dragon
Balls Zeno himself will bring back all
of the universes if the theory that I
outlined in mind what if the grand
priest is actually good video is true
then the grand priest is using the
tournament of power to teach Zeno
an important lesson the lesson is that
mortals actually have value and in xenos
case they have value because they can be
very entertaining as a creature who
exists on a higher plane of existence
Zeno cannot relate to mortals or truly
comprehend what he is doing to them when
he erases a universe if we look at both
Zeno
and future's I know during the
tournament of power we can see just how
much fun they are having watching the
tournament so once the tournament ends
in the seven losing universes are erased
Zeno will realize that he can never
watch another tournament like this one
again because most of the participants
are gone with only five universes left
all together any future tournament would
have less fighters less unique
techniques and so on at this point the
grant priest may approach Seto and
explain to him that if he wants to
continue being entertained by all these
mortals he has to bring the universe's
back to life and then he could
potentially organize regular tournaments
every few years for every universe to
showcase their best fighters like a
universe Olympic Games this would open
up the possibility of more major
tournament arcs in the future depending
on how long Dragon Ball super goes on
for but regardless of whether they are
brought back using the super Dragon
Balls or by the willows Enel I am
confident that the erased universes will
indeed be brought back into existence in
fact if they are brought back by super
shen rod and the wish that is made ends
up being general enough something like
bring every erased universe back without
specifying when exactly they were erased
we may even see the six universes that
Zeno erased before come back and that
would open up many new possibilities
what is going on in these six universes
are there powerful evil forces at work
in these universes that made Zeno mad in
the first place and made him decide to
erase them just like futures I know
decided to erase the entire future
timeline because of the evil deeds of
the masoom and speaking of the Matsui
I've gotten a lot of great comments from
you guys on my Dragon Ball super videos
in the past but this one really stood
out the commenter asks what if the wish
to bring back all the universes
ends up being along the lines of bring
back all the universes of the omni-king
race but then because of the way the
wish is phrased it also ends up being
applied to the universes that future
Zanna erase so that the entire future
timeline is brought back including Goku
black and za masu since future Zeno is
now in the present timeline we may not
even realize that the masu and Goku
black are back until they become
powerful enough to pose a major threat
to the multiverse once again I know that
a lot of people were fans of the mass
who as a villain so I wonder how his
potential resurrection would make you
feel let me know down below so the
possibilities that we talked about so
far include Frieza pulling off something
unexpected with the super Dragon Balls a
new threat emerging from one of the
universes that we haven't explored yet
including potentially the universes that
were raised by Zeno even before the
tournament and the possibility of the
masu being brought back by accident
another possibility for what happens
after the tournament involves super shen
rod and his creators Salama
the dragon god we really don't know much
about Salama the dragon god except that
he created the super Dragon Balls in
year 41 of the divine calendar we do
know however that super shine runs power
is without limits he is able to kill god
of destruction
grant immortality and even destroy
entire universes Vegeta speculates that
he can also bring back entire universes
after they have been erased and I think
that he is right super shine Ron's power
to grant wishes is without limits and
what is another word for without limits
omnipotent or simply Omni and who is the
only other being that we know with such
seemingly limitless power the Omni King
Zeno in my video called the Omni King
has a secret I argued that the only
being who could have created super
Shenron in the first place was none
other than Zeno no other being by
definition could possibly possess the
kind of power that could have created
super Shenron and that means that Zeno
is the creator of the super Dragon Balls
and that xenos true form is the dragon
God's allama future Senna was able to
erase infinite imasu even
though he had used the super Dragon
Balls to gain immortality and who could
undo the actions of an all-powerful
creature like super Shenron other than
its creator the dragon god on top of
that I believe that the biggest reason
that future settle decides to erase the
entire timeline in the first place
is that the mas who destroyed the super
Dragon Ball the supreme Kai's and gods
of destruction of the future timeline
can be replaced but the destruction of
the super Dragon Balls that might be
what convinced futures they know that
the future timeline is hopeless and if
this theory is true then the Omni King
having another form which is the Dragon
gods allama could be a major plot point
after the tournament of power perhaps
something will happen to Zeno like once
super Shenron is summoned after the
tournament something changes within Zeno
his overwhelming power erupts beyond his
control or something along those lines
this would then lead our heroes to learn
the truth above the Dragon God why he
was using another form what his true
intentions are how to stop his power
from destroying the multiverse and so on
I know that some people would also like
to see some non canonical material
brought into the Canon at some point
during Dragon Ball super including for
example Gogeta and the super saiyan 4
for these are not technically canon
because they appear only in movies and
in Dragon Ball GT and I know that a lot
of people assume that we will never see
Gojira or Super Saiyan 4 in Super just
because they aren't canon however it is
worth noting that bro Lee and his
legendary Super Saiyan power are also
not canon and yet when Kael was
introduced in Dragon Ball super her
Berserker Super Saiyan power and
appearance was revealed to be almost
identical to broglie's legendary super
saiyan so because of the example of kale
i wouldn't completely dismiss the
possibility of perhaps seeing Gojira or
some elements from Dragon Ball GT
introduced in Super personally I love
the design of Super Saiyan 4 and even if
they call it something else I would love
to see something like that in Dragon
Ball
finally a very popular theory at least
on YouTube is that the grant priest is
evil that he is manipulating Zeno and
that after the tournament he and perhaps
some of his angels will emerge as the
next major threat just searching the
words grand priest evil in a youtube
search will lead you to a ton of videos
many with hundreds of thousands of views
that talk about how the Grand Prix's is
evil this theory claims that the grand
priest wants the universes to be a race
so that the angels no longer have to
serve as attendants to the gods of
destruction and after all the universe's
are brought back by the super Dragon
Balls after the tournament the grand
priest will be upset by this and he will
seek to destroy those who made it happen
maybe after the tournament is over and
everyone goes home the grand priest will
put his plan into motion without Zeno
even knowing about it and some even
believe that the grand priest might try
to overthrow Zeno but I find this hard
to believe if we look at how powerful
Zeno is compared to the grand priests
and everyone else that we know in the
multiverse getting overthrown seems
pretty unlikely at any rate I firmly
believe that all of the erased universes
will be brought back after the
tournament and that we will learn more
about these universes and the mysteries
hidden inside of them after the
tournament ends but beyond that I want
to know what you guys think his fries
are going to make some kind of move yet
again will we see the return of the masu
will a new threat emerge from one of the
universes that we don't know very much
about maybe even one of the six
universes the Zeno erased earlier will
sin all turn out to be the dragon gods a
llama or will the grant priests become
some sort of villain and do you see that
we will see more non canonical elements
make an official appearance in Dragon
Ball super like Gogeta or the Super
Saiyan 4 design let me know down below
we always have great discussions in the
comment sections of these videos and
some of your comments go on to inspire
me to make new videos so please don't
forget to give me your take down below
what exactly do you think is going to
happen after the tournament if you enjoy
these videos and want to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you are new to the
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to stay in
touch on all the latest happenings on
this channel even when YouTube
notifications don't work properly then
you can follow us on Twitter at anime
uproar as always thank you all so much
for watching I really appreciate all the
support and until next time see ah space
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]